[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 22 février nice
et le littoral des alpes-maritimes
confiner les deux prochains week-ends
une mesure inédite en métropole à une
échelle locale avec l'espoir d'enrayer
la flambée de 4go vide dans le
département la campagne de prélèvement
salivaire elle a démarré dans les écoles
de la zone à
sur le front des vaccins sanofi va aider
à la production du vaccin américain
johnson & johnson et lance un nouvel
essai contre aux locaux vides
outre-manche le bout du tunnel en quatre
étapes avec elle afin d'enlever des
dernières restrictions qui qu'ovide fin
juin le premier ministre britannique a
déroulé cet après midi son plan de
déconfinement les écoles rouvriront
d'abord dès le 8 mars suivis des
commerces non essentiels à partir du 12
avril puis des stades le 17 mai une
avancée a pas à pas conditionnée à la
situation sanitaire précise boris
johnson
[Musique]
l'iran pourrait enrichir de l'uranium à
60% en cas de besoin le guide suprême
défie l'occident au lendemain d'un
accord in extremis avec l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique qui
est limite les inspections de ses
activités nucléaires en cas de maintien
des sanctions américaines
l'accord garantit une surveillance a
minima durant trois mois le temps que
les pourparlers diplomatiques entre les
parties de l'accord de vienne reprennent
[Musique]
sur le front du coc vide les prochaines
semaines toujours décisif face aux
variants tour de vis territoriale
dépistage le gouvernement poursuit sa
stratégie pour plus de précisions nous
retrouvons tout de suite mon âme ou dès
lors en direct de l'avenue de ségur
bonsoir mona de nouvelles mesures dont
de restrictions étaient annoncées dans
les alpes-maritimes ou d'épidémie flanc
depuis plusieurs semaines oui bonsoir
stéphanie c'est une première sur un
territoire métropolitain plusieurs
dizaines de villes comme menton nice ou
encore cannes seront concernés par ce
confinement partiel pendant au moins les
deux prochains week-ends ce confinement
il commencera par exemple à partir de
vendredi et 18 heures et se terminera
lundi à 6 heures du matin il faudra donc
des attestations pour sortir un petit
peu comme en mars dernier il faut dire
que cela fait des semaines que la
situation se dégrade notamment dans la
ville de nice où la circulation du virus
est beaucoup plus elle est élevée on
compte plus de 700 cas positifs pour
cent mille comptes m sont à cent mille
habitants pardon et le variant un
britannique fait partie d'au moins 50%
des contaminations les hôpitaux sont des
dons dans une situation s'est compliquée
cette décision du confinement parcelles
et bien vous l'imaginez elle ne fait pas
l'unanimité et mona hormis ce
confinement partiel quels sont les
autres mesures annoncées
alors plusieurs autres mesures ont été
annoncées par exemple pour les personnes
entre 50 et 64 ans ayant une comorbidité
et bien elles pourront désormais se
faire vacciner le plus rapidement
possible vaccin qui est proposé c'est l
astra zeneca le préfet a d'ailleurs
annoncé l'arrivée de 4500 dose de files
heures et puis pour les commerces de
plus de 5000 mètres carrés ils seront
fermés à l'excepté de à l'exception de
par exemple les commerces alimentaires
ou encore hey les pharmacies et puis les
contrôles vont être renforcés aux
frontières notamment à la frontière
italienne simona qu'en est il de la
campagne présent de dépistage massif a
lancé par olivier ferrand et bien les
élèves de la zone acp ont pu bénéficier
des tests salivaires à la rentrée des
tests moins rapide mais moins
désagréable pour ce jeune public pour le
gouvernement l'objectif est d'atteindre
au moins deux cent mille tests par
semaine alors que les médecins
généralistes pourront vacciner leurs
patients à partir du 25 février avec le
vaccin astrazeneca
les entreprises pourront également
bénéficier de ce même vaccin mais pour
un public précis seulement pour les
salariés âgés de 50 à 64 ans présentant
eux aussi des comorbidités merci mona
hameau dès lors en direct donc de
l'avenue de ségur et le confinement
territoriales dans les alpes-maritimes
une première donc en métropole à une
échelle locale et une nouvelle arme face
au co vide le prélèvement salivaire dans
les écoles pour revenir sur ces grosses
dernières mesures et ses conséquences
place à notre décryptage ce soir avec
nos invités
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec fred
quintrand vice-président de l'union des
métiers des industries de l'hôtellerie
des alpes-maritimes à nice
fred d'intrants qui est également le
patron de plusieurs établissements dans
la ville victor petit à vos côtés
directeur adjoint du développement de ce
qu'il sait laboratoire qui a développé
un test salivaire rapides de dépistage
de la cobi 19
bonsoir à tous les deux messieurs merci
d'être avec nous sur l'antenne berthet
france alors confinement partiel et
localisés sains pour les deux prochains
week-ends les commerçants ne sont pas
contents ils l'ont fait savoir
aujourd'hui vous les hôteliers également
les restaurateurs comment vous avez
accueilli cette nouvelle
aujourd'hui le plus c'est encore un tour
de 10 kg et qui est passé par le
gouvernement on trouve que c'est
évidemment heureux parce que ça c'est
des mois déjà que nous sommes fermés ça
fait des mois que gouvernement patauge
ce qu'on aurait espéré c'est une
campagne de vaccination qui soit un peu
plus vigoureuse si je puis dire que ce
qui se passe en ce moment c'est à dire
que la seule réponse du ministre de la
santé aujourd'hui ça a été de nous
donner 4500 doses de vaccins
supplémentaires et de resserrer un petit
peu plus la vie plus la 10 nous ce qu'on
aurait voulu que c'est pouvoir avoir des
solutions pour pouvoir vivre vivre avec
le virus parce que malheureusement on se
rend compte que malgré les confits
demande malgré les fermetures malgré les
interdictions
le virus continue de se propager
continuent de circuler donc il va
falloir un moment vivre avec c'est vrai
que les commerçants tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui on disait parleurs la voix
de leur représentant qu en gros ça ne
servirait à rien
c'est vrai qu'il faut rappeler quand
même les chiffres un peu inquiétant chez
vous métropole lilloise plus de 700 cas
positifs pour 100000 habitants plus de
trois fois la moyenne nationale
vous pensez que ça va servir à rien ces
nouvelles restrictions qu'elle n'était
pas nécessaire vous savez nous on a
toujours été
du côté du gouvernement est en tout cas
on a toujours prôné le fait qu'il
fallait évidemment protéger la vie par
rapport à l'économie
le souci c'est que malgré tout ça on se
rend compte au final qu'il n'y a pas de
succès et qui n'a pas d'avancer alors on
pourrait se demander si nice aujourd'hui
par rapport au fait qu'il y ait plus de
700 personnes le positif par rapport à
cent mille personnes testées ne le soit
pas parce qu'on fait beaucoup de tests
parce que dans la ville de nice on a
testé beaucoup on a été précurseur par
rapport à ça donc peut-être que ça
pourrait expliquer le fait qu'il y ait
beaucoup de tests positifs
la seule chose dont on se rend compte
c'est que malheureusement malgré tout ce
qui s'est passé
rien n'avance rien n'avance on est
encore à la traîne par rapport au vaccin
nous ce qu'on voulait en étant fermé on
s'est dit bon ben écoutez avec tous les
vaccinations qui veut dévorer on va
pouvoir reprendre une vie normale
là malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas
on va faire quoi on ouvrirait comment
ouvrir en septembre et donc
malheureusement il ya beaucoup de gens
qui se posent des questions et dont je
fais partie parce qu'on n'a pas de
visibilité on n'a pas de porte de sortie
nous ce qu'on veut c'est pouvoir
travailler on a été les premiers à
pouvoir affirmer malgré cela malgré des
mesures sanitaires très strictes
on a appliqué les protocoles je pense à
la lettre dans la grande majorité des
cas malgré tout ça on est mis sur le
côté et on se rend compte que l'épidémie
continue de progresser
donc on peut être en droit de se poser
la question de se demander si les
restaurants et des cinémas les hôtels
les lieux de vie sont vraiment des
facteurs de propagation du virus parce
qu'on voit que le virus de toute façon
circule toujours
qu'est ce qu'on va faire comme ça est ce
qu'on va continuer encore des années
comme ça à attendre 1 2 3 4 5 6 marion
différents pour continuer à vivre
je pense qu'il faut trouver les
solutions différentes et la vaccination
en tout cas je pense en fait partie
alors avant la vaccination peut-être les
tests victor petit je me tourne vers
vous déjà on va rebondir sur ce
témoignage et la situation niçoise vous
victor petit qui avait évidemment une
expertise très élevé en la matière des
tests on l'a dit à nice est une des
villes qui a le plus testé ces temps les
chaînes des tests on teste mal on isole
alors comment vous expliquez ça disons
que le test déjà il faut voir que les
technologies ont évolué et qu'elles ont
permis petit à petit de faire de plus en
plus de tests donc forcément quand on
teste plus de gens ont peut être amené à
détecter plus de gens positifs
cependant là où je pense qu'il ya une
sorte d'échec du test
on l'a vécu plusieurs épisodes dans ces
échecs c'est qu'aujourd'hui le test
j'entendais monsieur quintrand évoqué le
fait qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de secteurs
sont à l'arrêt en attente de
perspectives en attaque du vaccin en
attente de solution est typiquement on
aurait pu utiliser les tests certains
tests pour par exemple utiliser et
renforcer les protocoles et des des
mesures permettant des activités de
reprendre là où il ya eu un échec à mon
sens dans les tests c'est que la
stratégie le triptyque évoquée par le
gouvernement de tester d'isoler n'a pas
été à la hauteur étant donné par exemple
que certaines périodes de l'année et il
fallait des délais incroyable pour
pouvoir voir les résultats
plus on testera massivement mais avec
des tests qui sont fiables et qui donne
des résultats rapides
plus vite on prendra on pourra prendre
des mesures adéquates et faire
redémarrer quelque part une activité
quasi normale au pays quoi mais alors
justement victor petit on va le préciser
à vos tests les tests physiques up sont
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
désormais depuis début janvier
on vous a eu un très tôt en interview il
ya déjà plusieurs mois
si je me trompe pas à la rentrée
dernière en septembre dernier à la fin
de l'été pourquoi ça a mis autant de
temps les autorisations pourquoi c'était
aussi compliqué parce que ça aurait
peut-être pu changer la donne justement
pour les restaurants mais aussi miné de
la culture bon eh bien il est probable
que ce soit lié au fait que notre notre
test qu'on a développé en lien avec le
cnrs dont quand même une référence en la
matière ne rentre dans aucune case
enfin ne rentre dans aucune case
préremplie c'est à dire que c'est un
test qui a les performances d'un test
pcr qu'on connaît mais qui donne des
résultats assez rapidement beaucoup plus
rapidement que les tests pcr dont on
parle tout le temps être tantôt par
notamment dans le cadre du dépistage des
écoles tests salivaires par rt pcr
le fait qu'on soit avec une technologie
innovante et qu'on ne rentre pas dans
les cases c'est peut-être ce qui a fait
que les autorités ont eu besoin de
beaucoup de temps pour se faire une idée
sur la performance de nos tests sur la
façon dont ils pouvaient utiliser
et puis il ya peut-être aussi le fait
qu'on ait une toute petite société
montpelliéraine qu'on a développé sa au
tout début de la pandémie on est
d'ailleurs ravie qu'aujourd'hui la
salive sont reconnus comme comme
solution viable étant donné qu'on a fait
ce pari là depuis depuis le début de
l'année 2020 tout ça fait je pense notre
taille le fait qu'on rentre dans aucune
case et qu'on soit très innovant a fait
que du coup les pouvoirs publics ont
pris du temps pour avoir un avis sur
notre test et c'est bien dommage parce
que d'autres d'autres pays ont fait le
choix plutôt que la france 2 pariait sur
notre test et ont pu le mettre en place
depuis depuis l'été 2020 et il utilise
aujourd'hui de façon très courante quand
vous entendez ce témoignage des tests
très rapide fiable puisque on en a
souvent parlé ici sur ce plateau et
qu'on voit que ça n'a pas été utilisé
quel est votre conclusion vous on est
trop frileux en france on est trop
conventionnel trop lent quel est votre
avis là-dessus
vous savez je vais je vais essayer
d'être un petit peu tolérant par rapport
au gouvernement parce que
malheureusement ils ont connu une
situation que nous n'avions jamais connu
jusqu'à présent donc là dessus on va
dire qu'on a on va voir un petit peu de
tolérance
par contre quand j'entends les propos de
monsieur petit je me dis qu'il ya encore
de l'espoir et qu'on peut encore changer
les choses parce qu'il n'est jamais trop
tard est ce que je me dis c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ici on arrive à tester
les gens d'une façon rapide sur pourquoi
ne pas reprendre une activité on a déjà
fait des tests
il ya eu un essai avec un concert je
crois paris où 500 personnes en plus la
cité un concierge avait été testé
toutes négatives à partir du moment où
on est négatif on n'est pas positif au
virus je pense qu'on peut vivre
normalement
si on arrive à faire à mettre en place
ce système ce procédé est qu'on arrive à
le faire en masse je pense qu'on
pourrait arriver à reprendre à reprendre
une vie normale
et si en tout cas des mesures qu'il faut
essayer parce qu'on se rend compte
malheureusement que les comptes finement
les interdictions ça ne fonctionne pas
non ça va pas de résultats probants donc
je pense qu'il faut vivre vivre
différemment certes mais il faut vivre
avec
avec des moyens nouveaux donc les tests
salivaires de l'entreprise de monsieur
petit je pense même en faire partie
alors en attendant ça n'a pas été
retenue concernant nos écoliers puisque
vous le savez les tests salivaires des
buts pour la zone à c'était la grande
négociation aujourd'hui mais pas se dit
zico va alors je précise
la haute autorité de santé qu'il dit
nous poursuivons les échanges avec
l'industriel un don vous mais nous ne
pouvons pas encore rendre d'avis car une
étude de l'assistance publique est en
cours de réalisation et qu'il faut que
nous prenions en compte des résultats de
cette étude c'est ce que précise donc la
directrice de de la haute autorité de
santé
c'était le 11 février donc il ya
quelques jours si les données sont
positives nous pourrions l'ajouter à
l'arsenal victor petit vous étiez déçu
de ne pas faire partie justement de cet
arsenal et des tests qui ont été
sélectionnés par l'éducation nationale
vous avez eu un début d'explication
bien sûr que nous étions déçus étant
donné que de toute façon comme je
voulais dit on a fait le pari de la
salive très tôt que notre but est de
justement d'utiliser les tests pour pour
stopper ou pour freiner au maximum cette
pandémie donc du moment qu'on n'utilise
pas notre notre test forcément on est on
est peiné de devoir qu'une technologique
et performante et qui donne des
résultats résume rapidement et donc il
peut être utilisé qui peut être
particulièrement adaptées dans certains
contextes n'est pas utilisé maintenant
effectivement la has continue d'explorer
du coup les les études périphérie qui
utilisent notre notre testico mais là où
on est on est embêté c'est que nous les
études cliniques ont été on est entamée
l'année dernière on a fourni un certain
nombre de résultats
nous on a jugés probants que d'autres
états ont jugés probants et suffisant
pour prendre une position concernant
l'utilisation du test
donc je comprends la haute autorité de
santé qui a besoin de prendre des avis
extérieurs qui a besoin de regarder les
tests qui se font mais aujourd'hui on
avait une base scientifique quand même
suffisamment solides pour pour donner
des avis fred bien le mot de la fin pour
vous puisque je rappelle que vous êtes
en quelque sorte le représentant d
hôtellerie niçois des hôteliers niçois
aujourd'hui christian estrosi qui dit ne
venez pas ce n'est pas le le moment
difficile pour le maire de la ville
on imagine en tout cas pour vous écouter
ça vous savez je pense que christian
estrosi évidemment est en tout cas je le
pense est un bon maire il veut protéger
des niçois du mieux qu'il le peut je
voudrais juste clarifier la situation
aujourd'hui à nice huit hôtels sur dix
sont fermés d'accord et sur les deux
hôtels restants qui sont ouverts sur les
10 ils ont un taux de remplissage moyen
de 15% dont je vous laisse faire le
calcul
je peux vous garantir qu'à l'heure
actuelle en tous les cas ce ne sont pas
les touristes d'accord qui ont fait
exploser le taux de 2 de positivité au
virus et j'aimerais simplement conclure
si vous me le permettez sur des tests
salivaires notre président a dit que
nous étions en situation de guerre pas
de souci et bien aux situations de
guerre on prend parfois des décisions
urgentes dans l'urgence des décisions de
guerre et je pense que les tests
salivaires aurait dû être aurait dû être
utilisé même s'il nous n'avions pas le
recul nécessaire pour savoir si il est y
est plus fiable qu'un test pcr aucun
test antigénique peu importe je pense
que c'est ce qu'on aurait dû faire
aujourd'hui on préfère fermer une classe
d'école par exemple plutôt que de faire
les tests salivaires et mettre de côté
les élèves qui sont positifs on pourrait
en faire tout autant pour les théâtres
pour les cinémas pour les hôtels pour
les restaurants et pour toutes les
affaires qui font que nous puissions
vivre l'hérault nous remettre à vivre
normalement
voilà merci en tout cas pour ce mot de
la fin friends un gain sans victor petit
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france
et la situation s'améliore au
royaume-uni boris johnson a dévoilé cet
après-midi les grands lignes du
déconfinement en angleterre qui
démarrera le 8 mars
pour rappel les onglets sont mis sous
cloche depuis le 5 janvier dernier les
détails et explications avec quantum
auclair submergé il ya quelques semaines
le royaume uni relève désormais la tête
le 8 mars prochain
les anglais commenceront leur
déconfinement après plus de deux mois et
demi sous cloche
ce lundi le premier ministre britannique
boris johnson a dévoilé la ligne de
conduite choisi par le gouvernement
l'étape 4 commencera au plus tôt le 21
juin avec des mesures d'atténuation
appropriées
nous nous efforcerons de supprimer
toutes les limites légales concernant
les contacts sociaux les mariages et
autres événements de la vie nous
ouvrirons tous y compris les boîtes de
nuit et autoriseront les grands
événements tels que les représentations
théâtrales au delà des limites de
l'étape 3 en recourant éventuellement au
dépistage pour réduire le risque
d'infection
cette levée des restrictions
constituerait la quatrième et ultime
étape du plan de déconfinement avant
cela le gouvernement soit rouvrir les
écoles le 8 mars prochain
dans deux semaines les élèves et les
étudiants de toutes les écoles et de
tous les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur pourront reprendre
l'enseignement en présentiel en toute
sécurité grâce à des tests effectués
deux par semaine sur les élèves du
secondaire et des universités
les commerces sont essentielles sont
quant à eux concernés par la deuxième
étape du déconfinement à partir du 12
avril
en 3e étape le retour des spectateurs
lors des événements sportifs est espérée
à partir du 17 mai à travers ces quatre
étapes
boris johnson semble ne pas vouloir se
précipiter il est tellement crucial que
cette feuille de route soit prudente
mais aussi irréversible nous nous
engageons sur ce qui je l'espère et je
le crois devrait être un chemin en sens
unique vers la liberté et ce voyage est
rendue possible par le rythme du
programme de vaccination
si les dates annoncées ne sont pas
figées elles sont néanmoins porteuse
d'espoir outre-manche alors que le
royaume-uni est le pays européen le plus
meurtri par la pandémie
et pour revenir sur le plan de
déconfinement anglais nous sommes en
direct depuis liverpool avec francesco
rizzotto professeur de droit européen
l'université de redjil c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir francesco rizzotto merci devrait
avec nous en direct sur arte france une
première réaction tout d'abord à ce plan
présenté par boris johnson assez prudent
trop prudent selon vous ce cas faut je
pense que c'est un plat de prison et
pour moi le premier ministre a
aujourd'hui développer la feuille de
route donc soumise à plusieurs critères
à qui se déroulera entre aujourd'hui en
fin juin
j'ai donc ce calibre et emea conditions
c'est cela fait sens mais c'est
effectivement une feuille de route qui
offre une sortie donc c'est positif
alors c'est vrai que nous français
pardonnez moi on est fasciné par cette
feuille de route très précise qui va
jusqu'en juin fin juin
ici celle inverse on agit en fonction
des chiffres
le fait d'avoir un calendrier ça rassure
les anglais comment réagit style à ce
plan l'homme affirme avoir une feuille
de route je pense que cela arrange
beaucoup une heureuse la lueur au bout
du tunnel semble être apparue donc de ce
point de vue les gens sont heureux et
que nous pourrons partir en vacances
d'ici à fin juin pour lui rendre
cob en mai ne pourra nous faire couper
les cheveux en avril et à partir du 2
mars nos enfants pourront se rendre à
l'école donc c'est une forme de
libération
cependant le gouvernement et la
population ne doivent pas refaire
l'erreur de croire que
c'est fixé nous serons libérés cela sera
la fin gouvernement a espacé quatre
étapes de cinq semaines et les a
soumises à quatre critères très
importants qui doivent être remplies
toutes les 5 semaines sur le déploiement
du vaccin doit continuer
le vaccin doit lui le taux
d'hospitalisations et de décès
loto de contamination ne doit pas
repartir à la hausse afin que les
hôpitaux on puisse continuer à traiter
les malades afin que le nhs ne soit pas
submergés et bien sûr mais nous ne
devons pas voir arriver de nouvelles
vagues de nouveaux variants qui pourrait
s'appeler l'action du vaccin
donc ce sont des critères très rigoureux
très exigeant et cette feuille de route
lui ne suivra ce calendrier que si ces
quatre critères sont respectés
l'expérience suggère qu'il y aura des
variations cependant effectivement c'est
une sortie c'est une issue mais l'aco
vide nous a appris que rien n'est jamais
aussi ferme aussi gravé dans le marbre
qu'on aimerait le croire
en france si je peux non à revenir à
cela le problème c'est que la façon dont
le français les italiens l'ont fait pose
problème on nous rappelle les
entreprises pharmaceutiques ne
produisent pas les vaccins à un rythme
suffisant c'est en deçà des pro crêtes
des promesses et de le programme de
vaccination va être plus lent c'est tout
simplement cela et c'est celle à cause
du grand conflit entre de la commission
et les entreprises pharmaceutiques on a
de l'avancé mais il y aura des conflits
concernant ce que j'ai dit il ya
quelques semaines un dans une autre truc
dans un autre entretien environ en dix
ans n'est pas qu'il n'y aurait pas de
nationalisme vaccinale c'est ne pas tout
à fait du nationalisme vaccinale mais
les entreprises pharmaceutiques ne
jouent pas franc jeu pour tout le monde
enfin que j'adore les autos surtout vous
en étant sorti de l'europe vous n'avez
vous dû vous mettre d'accord qu'avec
vous même mais la france dû se mettre
d'accord avec les 26 autres pays de
l'europe est ce que c'est pas là que le
bât a blessé
justement il fallait faire jouer la
solidarité européenne solidarité face on
april avantages d'une pas pour des
raisons complètement idéaliste heures et
l'immoralité
la réalité est la suivante heures au
royaume uni 33% de la population a été
vaccinée soit 17 millions mais nos
frontières sont fermées
l'autre économie en souffrance donc
partir tout seul de ce côté n'est pas
forcément la solution car si on joue
solo mais qu'on ouvre les frontières le
fax un bar entre le virus soit résolu
hier donc la solution européenne n'était
pas mauvaise
la question de l'autorisation trop lente
des vaccins était un problème mais on
peut dire qu'il est mieux de prendre des
précautions et de vérifier quels sont
les effets secondaires avant de
distribuer des vaccins
je pense qu'en europe le véritable
problème c'était le manque de vaccins
l'approvisionnement en vaccins et
certains pays ont découvert que ces
vaccins sont vendus dans des marchés
parallèles
c'est un véritable scandale le royaume
uni avait l'avantagé parce
qu'effectivement il pouvait prendre des
décisions unilatéralement cependant
rappelez-vous que plusieurs milliers de
personnes sont mortes dans ce pays bien
plus que dans les autres pays de l'union
européenne
donc nous avons payé un prix pour les
erreurs de notre gouvernement et pour
notre soi disant liberté
donc il ya un équilibre difficile à
trouver pour moi je cavalier seul de
protéger mais au bout d'un moment il
faut ré ouvrir ses frontières
et si les autres ne sont pas vaccinés
alors tout le monde souffre merci
francesco rizzotto professeur de droit
européen diversité de et jill d'avoir
été avec nous en direct pour vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons espagne où les
manifestations se poursuivent depuis
près d'une semaine maintenant prêt
l'incarcération du rappeur pablo à zelko
vu comme une atteinte à la liberté
d'expression et puis direction l'iran
theron qui salue un accord significatif
et que l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même la
minustah elle compte au moins quatorze
mille militaires et policiers déployés
au mali ou non s'est elle fasse c'est
une mission de paix de la chose unis
mais la vérité c'est qu'elle évolue dans
un environnement difficile quand on vend
un ennemi un ennemi invisible
un ennemi qui ne connaît pas les
frontières qui ne connaît que la
brutalité qui est là pour faire du mal
mais grâce à notre détermination nous
sommes très différents
on a le sentiment c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sahel contre les
terroristes quel est votre constat la
menace terroriste est une menace globale
et que sa réponse quand on doit être
plus souvent là et la solidarité
aubin
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez en
catalogne la mobilisation pour soutenir
pablo hazell se poursuit le rappeur a
été condamné à neuf mois de prison ferme
pour apologie du terrorisme et injures
contre la couronne et des institutions
de l'état
la condamnation concerne 64 tweets
publiés entre 2014 et 2016 est une
chanson sur l'ancien roi d'espagne juan
carlos
ce soir c'est la septième une
mobilisation consécutive les précisions
à barcelone de leslie sinda les
manifestants se sont donné rendez vous
dans le centre ville de barcelone où un
vaste dispositif policier a été déployé
puisque depuis près d'une semaine
chaque soir les rassemblements se
termine en émeutes alors ces derniers
jours il y a eu du mobilier urbain
dégradé des magasins vandalisés des
containers et des motos brûlé il ya même
des pétards et feux de bengale jetés sur
la police
alors à barcelone on comptabilise plus
d'un million d'euros de dégâts en
catalogne ce sont 109 personnes qui ont
été arrêtées dont plusieurs avaient déjà
des antécédents pour trouble à l'ordre
public ou pour des délits comme des vols
et en
pour cent des personnes arrêtées étaient
des mineurs alors plus qu'un mouvement
pour demander la libération de pablo
hazell c'est devenu un mouvement pour la
liberté d'expression
il est demandé que des excès verbaux
comme lors de manifestations artistiques
culturelles ou intellectuelles ne
concerne plus le droit pénal afin que
les peines de prison soit exclu alors de
son côté le gouvernement a condamné les
violences la vice-présidente fait même
la différence entre défendre la
démocratie la liberté d'expression et de
l'autre côté les personnes arrêtées et
blessées alors le gouvernement a reconnu
qu'il fallait changer la loi afin d'en
finir avec les peines de prison et pour
éliminer l'insécurité juridique et pour
en parler nous sommes avec desbriel
colomé professeur en sciences politiques
à l'université de barcelone bonsoir
gabriel colomé merci d'être avec nous ce
septième nuit consécutive donc de
manifestations en espagne comment
expliquer cette détermination des
manifestants
je vous dirai qu'ils ont soir je dirais
que il ya trois cigm en dodon a donné le
groupe de manifestants il y a il y
aurait un parti politique anti système
qui est la coupe qui est en train de
faire entrer en négociation avec eux les
autres de partir dépens d'istres pour
entrer
deuxièmement il y a dd ce n'est des
vandales des gens qui font directement
des éléments de deux contres
bon de vandaliser de prendre des gants
comme on a vu des versace hier a été
lancée samedi par ont été saccagés et
finalement le troisième groupe le plus
important c'est le groupe déjà qu'ils
sont en train de manifester leur âge
leur indignation pour n'a pas savoir un
futur qui n'est pas possible en ce
moment c'est à dire c'est une génération
qui a vécu de toute chose très
importante c'est à dire une crise
économique pour mort en 1929 et
maintenant une pandémie comme la fameuse
grippe espagnole de 1918 c'est à dire
que c'est une génération que très
préparé mais n'ont aucun futur ils sont
tous dans son sang pouvoir voir quelle
sera la prochain parle dans une société
qui est en train très grave éléments
d'économie a pas de futur
ces jeunes c'est à dire ces trois
éléments qui se sont mis à côté de
l'autre mais voilà ça c'est le problème
est précisément qui sont ces
manifestants pendant qu'on comprenne pas
ce qu'on imagine peut-être que ça va au
delà de cette affaire pablo à celles qui
sont ils
et qu'est-ce qui le veulent exprimer le
premier groupe c'est eux les extreme
exprime pardon je dirais la logique
anarchiste anti autoritaire et entrions
y contre la police c'est en plus un
parti qui est en train de négocier avec
eux
le futur gouvernement une république 1
et 2 du parti de monsieur plus de monde
et qui sont en train de réclamer une
logique un modèle de police tout à fait
anti autoritaire c'est à dire un parti
anti système qui est contre la police
qui demande un nouveau modèle de police
au futur nouveau gouvernement
1er le premier segment premières
deuxièmes des groupes qu'on a connu en
dix neuf en 2019 quand après la sentence
du procès contre les dirigeants
indépendantistes qui ont si pendant
presque une semaine ont mis à feu et ont
saccagé la ville de barcelone il ça
c'est aussi les groupes vendent ali
qu'ils n'ont rien à voir avec les autres
et finalement le groupe majoritaire ces
sites ceux qui expriment littéralement 7
comment dirais-je ce malaise
le malaise de ne pas avoir un futur
d'être une génération très préparé c'est
ces gens qui sont des gens qui déjeunent
qu'ils ont entre 19 20 ans et 35 ans
c'est les millennials etc
cette génération qui ne parvient pas à
se faire un espace un creux dans un
créneau dans l'économie ni dans la
société
en ce cas espagnol je crois que c'est un
problème au niveau européen et sûrement
mondial c'est une génération très
préparée qui n'a pas de possibilité de
la voir par exemple un héritage où on va
voir n'avoir un couple pouvoir vivre
ensemble pourquoi parce que ils ont
parfois ils n'arrivent pas à la fin du
moins avec ce qu'ils y reçoivent comme
argent pour le travail qu'ils font qui
sont pas des titres écran travail il ne
sort pas beaucoup d'argent en tout cas
les les artistes prennent part à cette
affaire 200 artistes précisément dont le
cinéaste très connue elle modo var
électeurs radiés bardem qui ont signé
une pétition pour la défense ont
également dû du rappeur et son et contre
son incarcération
est ce que c'est une affaire qui va
vraiment au delà de la politique c'est
une affaire qui va marquer un tournant
dans la société catalane s'est pas
tellement un tournant parce que c'est
pas la première fois qu'on vise c'est
les semaines de qu'on dirait pendant
dirais-je de la barcelone en feu on a
vécu ça déjà en octobre 2019 c'est le
même parti la coupe est seul et jeunesse
de ce parti s'appelle anne qui profite
la sentence du rappeur ou d'autres
éléments pour sortir et faire ses
devoirs revendication constante parce
que ils ont un seconde c'est à dire le
la voie pacifique
on n'arrive à rien fait avec la voie
pacifique c'est à dire on va éliminer on
va se confronter contre l'êta à partir
de la violence c'est à dire
si vous me permettez c'est comme si on
revient à la barcelone des années 22la
1920 quand on appelait cette ville la
rose de cheveux parce que l'anarchisme
était très très virulent et très fort
ici c'est à dire que voir cette ville
brûlé c'est pas la première fois dans
les derniers cent trente ans c'est à
dire c'est pas nouveau et c'est possible
que ça continue aujourd'hui il y en aura
un autre une autre nôtres finalement ça
s'arrêtera et jusqu'à la prochaine où on
ne sait pas quel sera le motif pour que
recommence cette mon dirige c'est un
l'indignation les gens orages les jeunes
âgés qui sortent pour protester pour
différents motifs comme jelly politiques
ou personnelles de sang à venir c'est à
dire que et finalement pour le lait sur
les vandales hic qui font ce qu'ils font
mais c'est pas la coupe c'est vraiment
ce qui nous construisent les barrières
les barricades
c'est pas les vandales et que les
vandales hic ce sont différents ils
attaquent directement le magasin mais la
stratégie de la coupe c'est la
confrontation avec la police est avec
l'état l'état autoritaire et répressif
ça c'est le la logique idéologique qui
sont ans qui pratique depuis beaucoup
d'années
merci gabriel colomé professeur en
sciences politiques à l'université de
barcelone merci à vous
l' agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique annonce avoir trouvé un accord
temporaire avec un l'iran pour maintenir
en partie section de contrôle sur les
opérations nucléaires de téhéran et ce
alors qu'une loi iranienne doit être
appliquée dès demain pour limiter ces
inspections
les etats unis se disent prêts à
reprendre les négociations si téhéran
respecte de son côté ses engagements et
dernières informations avec françois
xavier lambert et grégoire dos et un
accord provisoire avant une reprise
formelle des négociations sur le
nucléaire iranien
à deux jours de l'entrée en vigueur
d'une loi restreignant les inspections
en iran de l'agencé internationale pour
l'énergie atomique
les pourparlers entre les deux parties
ont abouti après d'intenses discussions
dans la capitale iranienne
le directeur de l'eeie a salué cette
première étape il y aura moins d'accès
je le reconnais il y aura moins d'accès
mais nous avons été capables de
maintenir le degré nécessaire de
contrôle et de vérification pour ce que
nous définirons comme un accord
technique temporaire de son côté dire
ensemble pourtant peu enclin à faire des
compromis sans contrepartie
dans un communiqué le guide suprême
assure que téhéran pourrait enrichir de
l'uranium à 60% le cas de besoin et
dépasser ainsi largement la limite des
20 % autorisée par l'accord sur son
programme nucléaire
le chef de la diplomatie iranienne a
également justifié la loi encadrant les
inspections de l'aiea et dead man for
the ball climat ce n'est pas une date
limite pour le monde ce n'est pas un
ultimatum
il s'agit d'une question intérieure
entre le parlement et le gouvernement
mais nous sommes une démocratie nous
sommes censés appliquer les lois du pays
et le parlement a adopté des lois
que cela nous plaise ou non du parlement
adopte une fermeté également affiché par
les états unis
le secrétaire d'état américain a assuré
que washington était prêt à discuter à
nouveau avec téhéran si l'iran respecté
ses engagements le président biden a
déclaré que si l'iran se conformait à
nouveau strictement à l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
les etats-unis étaient prêts à en faire
de même en collaboration avec nos alliés
et partenaires nous chercherons
également à prolonger à renforcer cet
accord ainsi qu'à traiter d'autres
sujets de préoccupation notamment le
comportement des stabilisateurs de
l'iran dans la région et le
développement et la prolifération des
missiles balistiques autres pays
signataires de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien la russie se montre plus
optimiste
moscou s'est félicité de la reprise des
négociations entre les yeux à l iran
l'aiea et l'iran ont apporté une
contribution positive à la mise en place
des conditions pour le début d'une
conversation de fond entre les parties
sur le retour de washington dans
l'accord
nous allons ces étapes espérons qu'elles
aideront à améliorer la situation
politique autour de l'iran et son
programme nucléaire ainsi qu'à réduire
les tensions alimentées par les
opposants de l'accord
cette reprise des négociations sur le
nucléaire iranien survient alors que
l'accord de vienne conclu en 2015 ne
tenait plus qu'à un fil après le retrait
unilatéral des états unis en 2018 on
réplique téhéran avait décidé de
s'affranchir progressivement de ses
obligations sur la limitation de son
programme nucléaire
et pour en parler nous sommes avec toi
blanche maison expert en relations
internationales à bonsoir faut des
blanches maison merci d'être avec nous
un accord temporaire de trois mois donc
toujours une surveillance même réduite
durant ce laps de temps
iran aux états unis qui doit faire le
premier pas après tout ce sont les états
unis qui sont sortis comme vous l'avez
dit en 2018 de cet accord et l'iran
attend bien entendu que les états unis
qu'ont faits confirment par des actes
leur volonté de revenir dans cet accord
et pour l'iran césar ça doit être la
levée des sanctions économiques que les
états unis ont rétabli et d'ailleurs qui
sur le plan juridique sont peut-être un
peu fragile puisque la cour
internationale de justice il ya peu de
temps
c'est reconnu compétent pour le moment
venu statuer sur ces sanctions
économiques alors évidemment du côté
américain on a montré où aussi un peu de
bonne volonté d'abord en libéralisant
les conditions de circulation des
diplomates iraniens
à new york siège de l'onu ensuite en
retirant la lettre que l'administration
trump avait envoyé un l'onu au conseil
de sécurité pour utiliser l'onu comme
caution pour la la remise de sanctions
contre contre l'iran et que c'était
évidemment impossible puisque pour ce
faire les états unis utilisé à une
convention un accord dont il était sorti
par conséquent ils pouvaient pas
invoquer un article il prévoyait dans
certaines conditions la remise de
sanctions et puis effectivement ils ont
également saisi au bond l'opportunité
d'une invitation par l'union européenne
qui était également souhaité par l'iran
pour que tous les partenaires à l'accord
puisse se réunir dans les prochains
jours dans les prochaines semaines pour
discuter des conditions dans lesquelles
les états unis pourront se réinsérer
dans l'accord et l'iran appliquer toutes
ses obligations dont il s'était éloigné
le ministre des affaires étrangères
iranien avait d'ailleurs dit le 1er
février
nous nous attendons que monsieur josep
borrell le haut représentant pour la
sécurité et la coopération joue un peu
le rôle des chorégraphes c'est-à-dire
qu'ils règlent les petits pas que feront
les états unis et les petits pas que
feront l'iran puisque l'un et l'autre ce
défi du du partenaire du partenaire
adversaire et qu'il faut en effet
organisé la réinsertion de façon très
minutieuse
maintenant il y à un peu moins de trois
mois pour le faire alors qui a intérêt à
ce que les états unis ne reviennent pas
toute blanche maison dans l'accord de
vienne
l'israël israël a dit tout le mal qu'il
pensait de cet accord depuis depuis le
début il est clair que israël il ya les
élections très prochainement au mois de
mars
monsieur netanyahou va certainement se
dire que cet accord met en question la
sécurité d'israël d'ailleurs le chef
d'état major des fds salle de l'armée
israélienne a fait une déclaration tout
à fait étonnante il ya quelques jours
disons que
si cet accord revenez en vigueur peut
pleinement
eh bien il est possible que israël
doivent défendre sa sécurité
c'est une déclaration assez menaçantes
de la part d'israël à quelques jours
d'élections législatives qui seront les
quatrièmes en peu de temps et par
ailleurs évidemment l'arabie saoudite le
fait - savoir mais n'a aucune envie que
les etats-unis et les autres partenaires
de cet accord reviennent dans la danse
dans une négociation avec l'iran puisque
l'arabie saoudite et le grand rival de
l'iran pour le leadership du monde
musulman
d'autres pays ne le disent pas mais
regarde avec attention ce qui va se
passer parce que comme l'arabie saoudite
la turquie l'egypte considère que si
l'iran devait un jour se doter de l'arme
nucléaire et bien eux aussi devraient
sans doute suivre le même chemin donc on
est là devant une hypothèse de
prolifération extrêmement grave
alors l'accord de vienne qui ne soit
sauvée ou pas quel peut être l'impact
sur l'élection présidentielle iranienne
du mois de juin
l'élection présidentielle c'est le 18
juin et ce qui est sûr c'est que les
modérés ont déjà joué beaucoup sur cet
accord et n'ont rien obtenu
puisque le pari de monsieur rani
lorsqu'il s'est lancé dans cette
négociation qui a duré plus de dix ans
qui est une négociation terrible et bien
avait promis à la au peuple iranien que
les sanctions américaines et
occidentales seraient levés alors elles
ont été levées par les européens elles
ont été levées par l'onu mais les
américains après les avoir levé les ont
remises puisque monsieur trump a dénoncé
cet accord et effectivement là je crois
que les modérés sont en mauvaise posture
d'ailleurs dimanche soir hier soir
lorsqu'on a annoncé l'accord entre le
gouvernement iranien et l' agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
pour que les contrôles puissent
continuer tant bien que mal pendant
trois mois même s'ils seront un peu
restreint
par les décisions de l'assemblée et bien
l'assemblée l'assemblée nationale
iranienne a pris des décisions
extrêmement brutales contre le
gouvernement iranien interdisant aux
ministres de monsieur rani d'apparaître
dans l'hémicycle et disons qu'il
refusait de vue de voter le budget pour
l'année qui vient l année budgétaire
commence le 21 mars en iran donc un
conflit en effet entre un parlement très
conservateur et un gouvernement modéré
qui voulaient aboutir un accord et qu'il
veut obtenir ce que la population
demande c'est-à-dire la levée des
sanctions économiques qui sont
particulièrement dommageable le niveau
de vie a considérablement baissé en iran
il ya des pénuries dans certains dans
beaucoup de produits aux prix des
produits pharmaceutiques et puis on est
en pleine crise de covile et par
conséquent à une malédiction s'ajoutent
s'ajoute à la première merci claude
blanche maison et dans le reste de
l'actualité internationale en algérie
des milliers de manifestants alger pour
le deuxième anniversaire du irak
aujourd'hui est le mouvement de
contestation est à l'origine de la chute
d'aig d'elazig bouteflika il continue de
demander le départ d'une frange de la
classe politique même si l'actuel
président d'eads magie de tes boules ou
tentent de calmer le jeu avec la
promesse de législatives anticipées
retour sur ces deux années de
contestation inédite en algérie avec
françois-xavier l'envers
le 22 février 2019 une annonce va
déclencher la colère de la rue
algérienne
le président abdelaziz bouteflika
particulièrement affaibli fait part de
son souhait de briguer un cinquième
mandat
dans la foulée des milliers d'algériens
descendre manifester dans les rues des
grandes villes du pays le mouvement du
irak prend racine et va entraîner la
chute du chef de l'état algérien
le 11 mars abdelaziz bouteflika renonce
d'abord à se présenter à la
présidentielle
la volonté du irak est en partie que
c'est le 2 avril 2019 abdelaziz
bouteflika accepte de démissionner mais
pour les manifestants c'est insuffisant
ils réclament le départ des proches du
président démissionnaire ainsi que des
généraux qui dirigent le pays en
coulisses abdelkader bensalah est nommé
président par intérim le 9 avril 2019
deux mois plus tard il appelle un
dialogue lors d'un discours télévisé
après le report de la présidentielle
je vous appelle tous à opter pour la
voie du dialogue inclusif en vue de
tracer une feuille de route devant aider
à l'organisation par l'état du scrutin
dans les meilleurs délais dans la rue le
l'irak continue de maintenir la pression
des manifestations pacifiques se
déroulent tous les vendredis en
particulier à alger la présidentielle
est finalement fixé à la fin 2019
le 12 décembre 2019 abdelmadjid tebboune
un ancien fidèle d'abdelaziz bouteflika
remporte une présidentielle massivement
boycotté par l'opposition
il propose d'organiser un référendum
constitutionnel
près d'un an plus tard le 1er novembre
2000 vend une révision constitutionnelle
est approuvée par référendum en scrutin
marqué par le taux d'abstention le plus
élevé de l'histoire de l'algérie
le référendum se tient en l'absence du
chef de l'état atteint ducobu 19
fait hospitaliser en allemagne
abdelmadjid tebboune revient brièvement
à alger en décembre 2020 avant d'aller à
nouveau se faire soigner à berlin il
réapparaît à la télévision algérienne le
tous février dernier un retour aux
commandes du pays quelques jours avant
une reprise des manifestations le 16
février des milliers de personnes
manifestent à kherrata pour le deuxième
anniversaire du irak
là où avait eu lieu la première marche
deux jours plus tard le président
tebboune tends la main à l'opposition et
grassi des dizaines de prisonniers
politiques
il annonce également la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
j'ai décidé de dissoudre l'assemblée
nationale populaire pour appeler à des
élections qui soient kraft blanchie de
l'argent qu'ils viennent de la
corruption ou non david ouvrir les
portes à la jeunesse à cette dissolution
de l'assemblée nationale s'ajoute un
remaniement ministériel sans changements
majeurs
pas de quoi calmer les revendications de
l'opposition qui appellent à manifester
ce lundi partout en algérie est resté
avec mon dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur l' enquête lancée par la
ministre de l'enseignement sur l'islamo
gauchisme au sein des universités 600
universitaires et chercheurs appellent à
la démission de frédéric vidal et puis
nous parlerons de la crise vue
coronavirus presque un long saut cela
dure et la confiance des citoyens
français vis-à-vis de l'action politique
s'érode bien plus que chez nos voisins
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartements ont énervé
dans le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
moi je remarque qu'on ait passé un tour
de tracteur etc nous payerons campagne
il faut savoir c'est une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos métiers il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier à
quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos c'est
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille et je sais c'est de faire au
mieux c'est aussi tout en questionnant
sur la société sur le rapport à la
solidarité et le commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre donc dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois s'il faut un
évidemment
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi qui ait des
candidats n'y a pas d'alternative au
sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déçu l'univers l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose dignité
gilet jaune c'était des valeurs de
droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double y
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans on va te suicider
ça ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur ce retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que les gaffes à ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu les big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet ce
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dolhain des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham change les
équilibres stratégiques pour le moyen
orient
après 50 ans d'immobilisme dans cette
région complète tron était le seul à
pouvoir créer induction d'une paix
durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran tu n'iras les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords da
brains
[Musique]
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata papa parents
pata pata
vous avez envie de faire ça va aller il
faut que leur qu'istres groove la
musique c'est la traduction la plus
poétique de la vie si vous mettez pas la
vie des évidemment on s'embête il faut
sortir les notes de leurs univers
carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui a entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner et l' enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi 22 février les ministres de
l'enseignement doit taire doit-elle
démissionner dans une tribune publiée
samedi dans le monde universitaire et
chercheur demande le départ de frédéric
vidal plus de 600 d'entre eux reprochent
sa demande d' enquête sur l'islamo
gauchisme toute une profession qui se
sent diffamé par ce qu'elle dénonce
comme une chasse aux sorcières
la ministre elle précise qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de faire de polémique des sanctions
ciblées contre la violation des droits
fondamentaux russie birmanie venezuela
au congrès bélarus dans le viseur de
l'europe
les chefs de la diplomatie se sont
concertés aujourd'hui en visioconférence
si la réponse est proportionnée pour
certains n'a que peu d'effet déplore les
partisans d'action de réseaux atmosphère
tendue au niger dans les temps des
résultats de la présidentielle second
tour s'est déroulé hier ce que tu a
endeuillé par la mort de sept agents
électoraux
leur véhicule a roulé sur une mine dans
la zone dite des trois frontières en
froid on tient à 10 mhz les
dépouillements sont en cours
[Musique]
il y aura bien une enquête sur l'islam
en gauchisme dans les universités
frédéric vidal l'a confirmé hier dans
les colonnes du journal du dimanche
malgré la polémique une investi va
investiguer à sion d' approche
sociologique du cnrs précise la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur dans une
tribune 600 chercheurs et universitaires
appels à sa démission
une partie de la classe politique ainsi
que les signataires estiment que la
position du ministre de tutelle fait
planer je cite la menace d'une
répression intellectuelle à regarder
nous ne pouvons que déplorer l'indigence
de frédéric vidal annonçant le
répertoire de l'extrême droite sur un
islamo gauchiste l'imaginaire près de
son côté et la ministre de l'éducation
nationale montre au créneau jean michel
blanquer a rappelé hui les propos de
frédéric vidal l'islamo gauchisme et
selon lui je cite un fait social
indubitable il estime qu'il est
important de l'étudier ce serait absurde
de ne pas pouvoir étudier un fait social
si c'est une illusion il faut étudier
l'illusion et regarder si cela en est
une
pour ma part je le vois comme un fait
social indubitable lé salon gauchisme un
concept qui n'aurait pas de fondement
scientifique serait-il l'émanation d'un
ressenti de la population alors c'est
pourquoi nous allons demander quelle
était la définition l'estey mon
beau-fils m'écouter ces quelques
réponses
c'est pour faire agiter les gens pour en
faire peur aussi de faire réagir je
pense pas que c'est la bonne manière
mais c'est une méthode employée
actuellement par certains partis
politiques pour faire agir les gens
croient pas d'avis sur la question
et tombe plus étudiant depuis quelques
années un srec je suis un peu plus
éloignés ça donc n'ayant pas d'enfant
non plus avec ce côté éducation je suis
un peu plus en marge de ça donc j'ai pas
d'avis parce que j'aime pas ce concept
pour moi c'est antinomique
c'est introduire à mon avis d'une faute
de langage qui étaient reprises
d'ailleurs par
je mords d'extrême droite assez chiant
de pause voilà c'est juste chiant de
poser ce genre de questions et surtout
que c'est encore une fois une stratégie
mise en place comme on en connaît depuis
longtemps toujours détourné certaine
attention créer des polémiques voilà
c'est fatigant c'est juste c'est
épuisant et je je
j'en ai cure en fait c'est n'importe
quoi moi je trouve que le gouvernement
est ouvertement islamophobes en fait et
toujours cette machination s'est fait
toujours ses on retrouve toujours la
même chose dans les médias cet
acharnement contre les musulmans
moscou c'est sûr que c'est exagéré
enfin cet acharnement est ce cet
acharnement contre les musulmans enfin
je veux dire c'est incompréhensible
et surtout je veux dire que quand on
regarde les médias et ça peu importe
qu'ils soient bfm tv peu importe c'est
toujours la même chose et j'ai à présent
que les musulmans ils ont plus le droit
de vivre librement en france en fait
plaisir que les puits s'amuse à faire
l'amalgamé entre extrémistes et
personnes qui pratiquent la religion
dans la paix donc après il crée
l'amalgamé et crée aussi
la malle comme si les gens en fait il
les regarde je le peuple français qui
peu après ont l'image des musulmans
comme des terroristes comme des
extrémistes alors c'est pas du tout le
cas réponse de la ministre il n'y a pas
lieu de faire de polémique estime
frédéric vidal après donc ses propos sur
les universités françaises qui seraient
gangréné par l'islamo gauchisme et
pourtant depuis une semaine le monde
universitaire s'embrase on est par
l'économiste thomas piketty le
sociologue dominique méda universitaires
et chercheurs demandent la démission de
la ministre
frédéric du vidal il dénonce la chasse
aux sorcières menée selon eux par leur
ministre de tutelle
alors frédéric vidal doit-elle partir
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec nacira guénif professeur de
sociologie et d'anthropologie à
l'université paris 8 membres du
collectif vidal démission bonsoir madame
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés
cécile relax député la république en
marche troisième circonscription du val
d'oise bonsoir madame marie lac merci
d'être avec nous également frédéric
vidal qui est donc un dénoncer on l'a vu
dans les colonnes du jdd un procès
d'intention à son égard est ce que la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche a eu raison de dénoncer
ce courant de l'islamo gauchisme rampant
au sein des universités de réclamer en
tout cas à minima une enquête il ya
clairement un danger cécile relax selon
vous il y a pour moi pas de danger mais
il faut faire attention aux termes
employés
là où je ne suis pas d'accord ou jeudi
que en effet notre ministre a eu un
écart de langage sans employant le mot
islam gauchisme là j'en ai fait je ne
cautionne pas ce terme employé je ne
suis pas là c'est d'ailleurs par contre
ce que la ministre a voulu dénoncer
c'est une problématique qui est latente
depuis quelques années où l'ia dans
certaines universités n'ont pas de la
part des enseignants chercheurs mais de
la part des étudiants de certains
groupuscules une un amalgame qui est
fait un mail
deux genres qui est fait entre eux la
logique de recherche la logique
scientifique et le militantisme et
l'utilisation politique de certains
concepts
en fait je pense que là où la ministre
elle a raison de dire attention il y à
des concepts qui sont détournés
oui il faut qu'on y fasse attention donc
là elle parle petit clairement de
théories en sciences humaines et
sociales
on va parler des d'intersection nalité
on va parler des colonialismes tout ça
mais là où en effet moins de plus je ne
peux pas cautionner l'utilisation du
terme islam au gauchisme pas que cela
renforce ce mélange des genres qui à mon
sens n'est pas bon alors en tout cas le
monde universitaire on l'a dit est
vendeuse mois et demande sa démission à
la ministre je vous propose de revoir un
extrait de cette tribune publiée ce
week-end dans le journal bien le monde
si le propos manque de cohérence
l'intention est dévastatrice
il s'agit de diffamer une profession et
au delà toute une communauté
la taxe ne se limite d'ailleurs pas à
disqualifier puisqu'elle fait planer la
menace d'une répression intellectuelle
nous ne pouvons que déplorer l'indigence
de frédéric vidal la violence du projet
redouble la lâcheté d'une ministre resté
silencieux sur la détresse des étudiants
et étudiantes pendant la pandémie
n'attire à gagny vous faites partie de
ces signataires et vous demander
clairement départ de frédéric vidal
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus choqué
finalement dans cette affaire alors je
pense que ce qui est le plus choquant
c'est l'opportunisme le cynisme je ne
sais pas comment il faut lire dont fait
preuve la ministre alors que
le monde universitaire dans une
situation d'isolement de désorganisation
de détresse profonde dire cela en pleine
pandémie
face à des étudiants qui ne sont pas
tenues d'ailleurs avec quelconque devoir
de réserve du point de vue de leurs
opinions politiques
ils ne sont pas tenus à la scientificité
sont là pour apprendre
donc je ne suis pas absolument sûr de
comprendre la position de la des madame
la députée donc du point de vue deux des
signataires qui aujourd'hui ne sont plus
six ans ils sont treize mille nous
sommes treize mille signataires du monde
universitaire a demandé la démission le
départ de la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche parce que
alors vous comprendrez contre 6600
vendredi et 13000 aujourd'hui il y a
comme une unanimité que la ministre
doit assumer un sait les conséquences de
ces propos et aussi de ses actes je ne
me suis pas la seule à me souvenir que
depuis quatre ans toute une série de
lois de projets on visait à mettre en
coupes sombres l'enseignement supérieur
public français et c'est donc face à
cela que aujourd'hui nous considérons
que ces propos sont parfaitement déplacé
que c'est une manoeuvre de diversion
qu'elle a opéré pour détourner le regard
du fait qu' elle n'a pas cessé en fait
d'agir contre les intérêts du monde
universitaire et qu'elle s'est
désintéressé depuis de longs mois
dix sortes d'étudiantes et d'étudiants
qui aujourd'hui sont complètement livrés
et abandonné à une situation qui devient
proprement insupportable
et ce ne sont pas que les étudiants se
sont aussi les enseignants chercheurs et
tous les précaires de l'enseignement
supérieur qui aujourd'hui écoute avec
effarement les propos de la ministre
alors les deux maisons ainsi sur le fait
de vouloir faire une enquête
sociologique
étant moi même formé en sociologie
anthropologie je crois pouvoir en parler
en toute en toute quiétude
je ne devrais pas être ici pour
contester les propos de la ministre je
devrais être en train de faire le
travail pour lequel j'ai été formé et
pour lequel je suis fonctionnaire
or je dois aujourd'hui contesté les
propos du ministre et mettre en évidence
le fait que ce projet de recherche d'
enquête est absolument complètement
fumeux il n'y a aucune priorité aucune
urgence à examiner quoi que ce soit qui
serait approchant d'un phénomène
l'islamo gauchisme au sein de
l'université française
alors c'est si leur île à que les
raisons invoquées par frédéric vidal au
départ c'était protéger un jeu signe des
universitaires se disant empêché par
d'autres de mener leurs recherches
séparer ce qui relève de la recherche
académique de ce qui relève du
militantisme et de l'opinion est ce
qu'il y a clairement un problème de
méthode parce que quand on écoute un
madame gheniff on voit effectivement que
la contestation au sein du monde
universitaire grande idée
vous renvoie de 600 signataires dans la
colonne du monde on passe à 13 milles
elle aurait dû s'y prendre autrement la
ministre s'est en fait il
on est un carrefour de différentes
choses que ce que madame gheniff dénonce
il ya un cumul on entend bien qu'à la
problématique en effet des étudiants la
situation des universités qui est
extrêmement difficile depuis la crise qu
vide donc ça en effet sa cristallise
beaucoup beaucoup de désespoir de
désespérance à la part de nos étudiants
et c'est tout à fait normal que les
enseignants les enseignants chercheurs
et ben soit inquiet pour pour leurs
étudiants donc ça et ça c'est une
première chose ensuite il y a pour
certains usent universitaire une
opposition liées à la loi de
programmation sur la recherche ou les
estiment que cette loi ne va pas assez
loin or on a mis 25 milliards d'euros
sur les prochaines années pour supérieur
et la recherche
donc bon gars et enfin on arrive à cette
problématique là comme je vous ai dit
que le terme islam au gauchisme moi je
ne cautionne pas les propos de la
ministre par rapport à cela mais par
contre là où madame guenifi faut quand
même le reconnaître c'est que dans
certaines universités aujourd'hui on a
une problématique qui est que certains
jeux je le redis c'est bien des
groupuscules ce ne sont pas les
enseignants ce sont des groupuscules
étudiants ou alors même en extérieur
d'université qui empêche le dialogue qui
empêche le débat sur certains concepts
et pourront moi ce que la ministre c'est
cela qu'a l'a voulu dénoncer de dire
attention dans certains dans certaines
universités
il n'y a plus la possibilité de débattre
il n'y a plus la possibilité de
confronter des idées des des concepts
différents or l'université c'est quand
même bien le lieu celle ci lui dit
mourad aux rémois de cette importance et
pardonnez moi parce qu'on on arrive dans
le coeur du sujet parce que quand on les
voit là ici ou là l'islamo gauchisme et
bien franchement c'est pas toujours bien
ce que c'est donc justement c'est quoi
ces concepts dont on ne peut pas parler
franchement auront bien qu'on comprenne
de quoi une série en fête et de quoi on
parle alors si vous voulez que je vous
donne une définition du siam au
gauchisme personnellement je ne sais pas
ce que c'est
en tout cas moi j'ai été arrêté
longtemps que j'y parlais soir et demain
les concepts par contre où il est qui
qui entraîne des problématiques dans les
universités c'est quand on va utiliser
des théories aujourd'hui qui sont en
effet étudié en sciences humaines qui
sont le des colonialismes qui sont
l'intersexualité ou et où on voit qu'il
ya des groupes d'étudiants qui discutent
et qui vont interdire des réunions
mixtes qui vont faire justement des
réunions des mixains qui vont empêcher
des conférences de se tenir
qui vont cesser cela en fait qui est
dénoncé c'est ses loyers la différence à
dire que ce n'est pas le contenu
les enseignants et des enseignements qui
est dénoncé c'est l'exploitation par
certains groupes politiques et à des
fins militantes d'empêcher l'expression
de différentes conceptions
voilà donc ce sont ces enfin je pense à
la base mais je pense que madame gheniff
là-dessus sera d'accord avec moi que
c'est sur ces théories 2
intersectionnelle été particulièrement
des colonialismes se pose la difficulté
et madame gheniff je pense que vous êtes
d'accord que ce n'est pas normal que
dans certaines universités ne puisse pas
se tenir des conférences qui les en dés
des intervenants ou des chercheurs
qu'ils ne puissent pas exposer leur
approche de deux de ces données ou qu'on
organise des réunions qu'ils soient
interdites à certaines personnes
on va laisser nacira guénif répondrez
vous répondrais ce que vous constatez où
ce genre de phénomène clairement dans
votre université
non je n'ai pas croisé de groupuscules
et je n'ai pas connaissance de la part
de tous les enseignants chercheurs et
tous les collègues avec lesquels
j'interagis depuis des années maintenant
de quoi que ce soit qui relève d'une
action de groupuscules qui viendrait
empêcher le débat ou qui souhaiteraient
se
faire sécession pourquoi pas séparatisme
tant que lien n'est ce pas puisqu'il ya
quelques jours noirs là dessus a été
votée donc allons jusqu'au bout de de la
tendance et de la pente glissante sur
laquelle on veut nous installer non je
pense que les étudiants et les étudiants
sont parfaitement en droit de
s'approprier les théories qui sont
enseignées à l'université pour être très
clair
j'enseigne les théories des colonials
j'enseigne les théories du genre
j'enseigne les théories de
l'intersection qualités et j'ai face à
moi des groupes d'étudiants qui sont
parfaitement capables d'assimiler ce que
je leur enseigne d'en comprendre les
tenants et les aboutissants est
d'ailleurs souvent ils sont et elles
sont tout à fait capables de voir en
quoi est-ce que ça résonne par rapport à
la vie qu'il mène en france notamment
par rapport au phénomène de racisme
structurel ou par rapport au phénomène
de discrimination de sexisme et les de
racisme croisés donc ces théories sont
très utiles elles n'ont pas à être
évalués par une enquête extérieure qui
viendrait nous expliquer qu'elles ont
une légitimité quelconque cela se passe
dans lance dans l'enceinte de
l'université au sein des espèces de
controverse et de débats et il n'y a
aucune nécessité de réguler ces espaces
pour le moment qu'il y ait eu des
annulations de conférences ça reste
parfaitement minoritaires par l'ensemble
de toutes les activités qui se déroulent
dans les universités et qui ont
malheureusement été interrompue en
présence depuis le début de la pandémie
par contre je voudrais souligner que à
la demande du ministère il y a eu des
annulations de colloque non pas par des
groupuscules étudiants mais pas par
l'autorité publique par notre autorité
de tutelle qui a prétendu sans s'ingérer
en fait dans l'organisation de colloques
alors que nous sommes nous avons la
garantie de notre liberté académique et
ça ça n'a visiblement gêné personne à
l'époque ça s'est passé en 2017
il ya eu des enseignants chercheurs des
chercheurs qui ont été mis en cause leur
probité
parce que il voulait développer des
colloques qui avait été parfaitement
validé et financé d'ailleurs et donc au
dernier moment il ya une espèce
d'emballement il
aux logiques de panique morale qui a
conduit à la remise en cause de ces
colloques parce qu'il parlait d'
islamophobie
parce que non pas il en parle sur un
mode polémique et politiques qu'ils en
parlent pour étudier le phénomène pour
l'examiner pour le documenter nous
sommes dans des démarches de
compréhension du monde et non pas dans
des démarches de d'inflexion du monde
selon l'orientation idéologique qui sera
la nôtre ça on le laisse aux politiques
qu'ils le font très mal
actuellement alors justement jean michel
insiste là-dessus
notre travail c'est d'être à
l'université c'est de faire de la
recherche si je me trouve ce soir devant
vous ce n'est pas tant parce que je
prête une grande importance à ce genre
d'exercice c'est parce que nous y sommes
contraints par le climat qui est imposé
par le gouvernement depuis des mois et
depuis un peu plus d'une semaine par
notre ministre de tutelle des ministres
en tout cas jean michel blanquer air à
lui appuyé un les propos de frédéric
vidal liste m au gauchisme et selon lui
je cite un fait social indubitable
cécile annie lac
vous avez conscience dans la majorité de
ce terrain glissant précisément dans
lequel peut être vos amis frédéric vidal
aujourd'hui c'est une polémique dont
vous vous seriez peut-être passé où
finalement elle est assez saine et ma
foi il faut débattre de tout et on y va
franchement moi je pense qu'il faut des
bacs de tout mais par contre la
polémique dans laquelle on est actuel
est un oui c'est un terrain glissant sur
lequel je ne souhaite pas je souhaite
pas aller là par là pour le coup ce que
madame gheniff dénonce et je ne peux
qu'abonder dans son sens c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons quand même une
situation dans les universités qui est
extrêmement difficile pour nos étudiants
et la priorité elle est véritablement la
soutenir nos étudiants particulièrement
nos étudiants les plus précaires faire
en sorte qu'aujourd'hui il puisse y
avoir des cours qui reprennent
moi je sais que je suis extrêmement
attentive à cela donc sur mon territoire
c'est l'université de cergy pontoise
je sais que depuis le mois de janvier
j'ai rencontré des étudiants j'ai
rencontré
régulièrement je suis avec le président
de l'université parce qu'il ya une
grande volonté des enseignants du
président à des étudiants de pouvoir
reprendre le rythme normal
et en effet ça c'est une priorité et ça
doit être la priorité c'est pour ça que
je ne pour le coup je ne peux pas
cautionner ces polémiques qui nous
éloigne des en effet du véritable du
véritable sujet mais là où je ne suis
pas d'accord avec madame gheniff c'est
que passer en fait je suis d'accord avec
madame bénigne lorsqu'elle dit c'est son
boulot en effet c'est son travail
d'enseignant chercheur et il faut qu'il
y ait ces recherches sur toutes les
thématiques que nous quel hacker
l'abordé donc ce que l'on dénonce en
tant que politique c'est le fait de
dérives et lorsque vous dites qu'il n'ya
pas forcément moins pauvre j'te parle de
groupuscules
parce que lorsqu'il ya des pièces de
théâtre lorsqu'il est à des conférences
qui sont annulés je suis désolé ce n'est
pas que c'est pas vous les enseignants
qui interdisait les ce sont des
étudiants
ce sont des personnes extérieures et en
fait nous on a été en fait alerté bon ça
fait trois ans que j'ai je suis alerté
régulièrement est régulièrement par des
étudiants par des enseignants des
étudiants qui le disent là nous il ya
des cours on peut pas les suivre
que ce soit la sorbonne que ce soit à
paris xiii que ce soit à nanterre
université puisque ce sont des
universités d'île de france
voilà c'est la cc c'est pour ça que
manger je suis assez attentive là dessus
frédéric vidal doit-elle partir sur
l'envié je pense que en tant que députés
la majorité j'ai pas me prononcer là
dessus puisque c'est une décision
gouvernementale jeu une chose est sûre
c'est que s'il ya une maladresse qui a
été commise dans les propos de la
ministre je pense que elle a d'ailleurs
depuis bien repris et ré expliquer ce
qu'elle voulait faire c'est à dire de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait non pas une
enquête mais bel et bien peut-être des
travaux supplémentaires délégué à aller
en s'atténuant donc sous couverture du
cnrs voilà de 2,2 voilà deux piliers ces
théories qui soit peut-être approfondie
dans des travaux interdisciplinaires
mais là ce n'est pas du tout mon domaine
je pense que madame gheniff pour en
parler beaucoup mieux de
que moi parce que j'ai en effet je ne
suis pas au fait des spécificités de ces
théories qui sont l'apanage des sciences
humaines et sociales et il faut laisser
à nos enseignants chercheurs à nos
spécialistes aussi le soin de bien
expliquer ces concepts et là dessus avec
marc ganis pense qu'on sera d'accord
qu'il faut que ces concepts soit
enseigné qu'il soit débattu parce qu'en
effet ils permettent à notre société
d'évoluer et de comprendre le jeu les
intentions
oui attention direz vous le mot de la
fin aujourd'hui clairement on l'a
compris puisque vous êtes signataire on
le rappelle de cette tribune vous
demander le départ de frédéric vidal
mais finalement on est il pas ça comme
vous le faites d'ailleurs et on vous en
remercie ce soir de venir débattre et
expliquer et finalement dissiper tous
les malentendus parce que manifestement
il y en a des malentendus puisque deux
camps y compris au sein de la gauche
d'ailleurs qui se divise sur ces thèmes
voilà il ya des choses peut-être
n'ont-ils pas expliquer ce que ce débat
mais qu'il passa au final est est ce que
il n'est pas plutôt salvateur de la voir
alors tous les débats sont salvateurs
nous ne cessons de le pratiquer de
l'enseigné à nos étudiants le problème
c'est les circonstances dans lesquelles
il est imposé c'est la teneur qui nous
est aussi imposée c'est à dire cette
chasse aux sorcières cette façon de
désigner des coupables ou des formes de
deux logiques qui viserait à
à déformer l'esprit des étudiants donc
tout ça en fait est particulièrement
nocif tout cela est une perte de temps
pour tout dire
ces débats ont lieu ils sont
particulièrement productif
les études et les enquêtes qui repose
sur ces théories ont lieu elles ne sont
pas assez financer et l'état d'ailleurs
du financement de l'enseignement
supérieur je le rappelle ne risque pas
de faciliter les choses dans l'est dans
les années à venir puisque ce ne sont
pas des dotations pérenne mais c'est
bien des demandes de financement qu'il
faut passer sa vie à faire pour obtenir
des financements faire la recherche donc
pour toutes ces raisons aujourd'hui je
pense que effectivement le départ de la
ministre s'impose parce que elle a non
seulement ella ella ella ella chercher à
décrédibiliser le monde universitaire à
partir de cette accusation d'islam au
gauchisme qui n'est toujours pas précisé
d'ailleurs et qui continue de produire
des effets délétères et elle s'est
détourné de ses responsabilités à notre
égard en faisant faut voter des lois qui
aujourd'hui vont avoir des conséquences
gravissimes sur l'enseignement supérieur
si on ne met pas un coup d'arrêt à tout
cela donc la première chose à faire
effectivement c'est qu'elle parte pour
ce qui est d'organiser des débats des
controverses
nous savons le faire nous le faisons
régulièrement peut-être qu'au fond il y
a une difficulté qui consiste à
s'intéresser un peu plus à ce qui se
passe à l'université est un peu moins au
twitter et autres formules à
l'emporte-pièce qui sont constamment en
train de caricaturer la réalité si
effectivement on comprenait au sérieux
et on accordait la considération
nécessaire et légitime au milieu
universitaire et à ce qui s'y produit
sans doute que certains débats nous
seraient épargnés celui ci en est un
merci à vous en tout cas de la syrah
gheniff cécile rila d'être venus
débattre en direct sur arte france merci
à toutes les deux restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons des
sanctions ciblées européenne contre les
violations des droits fondamentaux cela
concerne la russie
le venezuela hong kong et new bélarus et
puis direction ensuite le niger ou le
payer dans la tente de résultats de la
présidentielle deux secondes au tour
s'est déroulé hier à ce que tu a
endeuillé par la mort de sept agents
électoraux
[Musique]
il ya à peu près un enfant sur deux en
france qui est soit victime soit hauteur
de cyber violence sur internet un
contenu haineux de quelqu'un qui dit à
une fillette de 8 ans va te suicider ça
ça doit être retirée immédiatement il
n'ya aucun débat à avoir sur son retrait
là parce que ça ça fait des suicides la
loi le condamne déjà c'est déjà interdit
de faire ça bien sûr mais c'est juste
que le légat fans ne l'appliquent pas la
justice est lente et c'est très
problématique qui doit prendre ce rôle
de régulateur la loi peut aider
l'éducation peut aider selon les
différentes catégories d'attaquants et
d'attaquer une erreur de la loi via ça a
été de tout mettre dans le même panier
sous le sous le nom et no line quel rôle
pour les réseaux sociaux on a vu et big
for donc les gaffes à s'organiser pour
annuler quelqu'un sur internet sur
quelqu'un c'était donald trump quand il
s'agit d'un bannissement si général pour
moi ce n'est pas aux gaffes à et aux
réseaux sociaux à dont la des
entreprises privées de prendre cette
décision mais ça doit être à la justice
de prendre cette décision
[Musique]
et
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française d'autres affirment
même que nous ne sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous êtes né dans la musique vous êtes
né dans une famille d'artistes désir
révélée brutalement par la prise de
conscience du concert symphonique qui
m'a donné envie d'être chef d'orchestre
ça a balayé tout le reste c'est un acte
d'amour la musique pour vous oui mais
l'art en général vous savez ça permet de
mieux se connaître ça permet de mieux
partager c'est la part d'humanité
incontournable et indispensable à
l'évolution de tout être humain quand
vous entendez pata pata pata pata pata
pata pata pata pata pata pas par an pata
pata
vous avez envie de faire ça il faut que
leur qu'istres groove la musique c'est
la traduction la plus poétique de la vie
si vous mettez pas la vie des évidemment
on s'embête il faut sortir les notes de
leurs univers carcéral
mais il faut jouer ce qui entre les
notes et avant tout c'est le rythme et
la pulsation et ça c'est fondamental
pour entraîner l enthousiasme des
musiciens et celui du public
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
la coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez l'union
européenne à la manoeuvre les chefs de
la diplomatie se sont concertés
aujourd'hui en visioconférence au menu
des sanctions ciblées contre
l'évoluation violations des droits
fondamentaux birmanie venezuela hong
kong bélarus sont dans le viseur mais
également la russie qui se dit déçu avec
une procédure pour sanctionner les
responsables russes dans le cadre de la
sphère un avanies par la voix de joseph
morehead les vingt-sept condamne
certaines décisions russe interprété
comme un désintérêt pour l'europe
symbole des dissensions entre moscou et
bruxelles la condamnation d' alexeï
navalni m malgré les mises en garde du
kremlin l'union européenne devrait
prendre des sanctions contre quatre aux
fonctionnaires russes pour venir à la
situation de monsieur navale où nous
sommes arrivés à un accord politique
visant à imposer des mesures
restrictives contre ceux qui sont
responsables de son arrestation de sa
condamnation et de sa persécution et
pour ce faire
pour la première fois nous utiliserons
le régime global de l'union européenne
concernant les droits humains il s'agit
d'un régime de sanctions sanctions qui
vont faire l'objet d'un processus
administratif à commencer par
aujourd'hui sous la houlette et la
responsabilité du haut représentant et
j'espère que une décision interviendra
rapidement sur ces sanctions
ça prendra peut-être une semaine mais
pas plus je l'espère et il y aura une
procédure écrite pour leur approbation
au niveau du conseil
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
karine bêcher cobol golovkov professeur
invité à l'université d'état de moscou
bonsoir karine
et chez golovkov merci d'être avec nous
des sanctions donc cibler la part de
l'europe avec un effet relatif voire
inefficaces selon vous en effet l'union
européenne vient simplement de démontrer
son efficacité totale à l'efficacité à
de cette politique des menaces
constantes
à partir du moment où la russie ne se
plait pas pippa parlement à la volonté
politique des la défense des intérêts
globaliste par les européennes
dans ce cas là l'union européenne a
qu'une chose à faire c'est prendre des
sanctions des sanctions qu'elle a déjà
prises rappelons le poème à l'occasion
d'un à vanity aussi en octobre dernier
donc maintenant elle continue puisque
toutes ces menaces ne servent à rien
c'est montre bien quand même que ce
pouvoir le baliste n'est efficace que
dans la mesure où il fait peur et où il
est respecté appartement ou un état
souverain défend sa souverainté ils sont
absolument impuissant alors les proches
de damas nie d'ailleurs se sont dits
déçus eux aussi évidemment ils sont
déçus ils sont déçus parce que c'est eux
aussi non seulement pour un signe de son
tour mais c'est une question de survie
financière puisqu'ils sont financés ils
sont à l'étranger tant qu'ils peuvent
produire du désordre en russie la
vanille en prison la russie ayant tenu
quelques sanctions uniquement politique
ou au théâtre aux prises contre quelques
personnalités ce qui fondamentalement ne
changera strictement rien au
fonctionnement de l'état en russie en
revanche cela va continuer a détérioré
les intérêts de la russie et de l'union
européenne soulignant absolument les
paroles de lavrov lors de la course de
la conférence de presse disant que
l'union européenne ait pas un partenaire
fiable et ça se confirme on leur a pas
qui semble tout de même divisés sur la
conduite à tenir face au kremlin
pour quelle raison parce qu'à
l'intérieur de des pays membres de
l'union européenne
louve
une fracture entre certains groupes
leaders monde ira dans la course 1 à la
russophobie qui entraîne le reste un des
pays de l'union européenne il sait il
est fondamental de différencier d'une
part l'union européenne en tant que
structure et les pays membres de l'union
européenne puisque la russie
développement et continent développés
contre ou à part de liant peint des
relations bilatérales avec certains
paiements qui se sentent intéressés à
continuer des relations bilatérales
dans ce cas on voit effectivement un
danger l'union européenne sans ce danger
puisque dans ce cas là c'est l'intérêt
de son existence qui est remise en cause
directement en fait tu parles d'une
politique d'état nation explique bien
des choses qu'on imagine non le
dépendance au gaz russe était avant la
dépendance au gaz soviétique il n'ya
strictement jamais eu de problème en
tout cas la russie union soviétique
avant n'ont jamais utilisé il le gaz les
ressources pétrolières pour faire un
chantage politique au pays européens ils
le savent pertinemment
en revanche l'on voit la montée des
intérêts économiques des états unis et
du monde globalis atlantiste contre le
marché tenu par la russie et plus
influents par la russie évidemment sur
le continent européen pour des raisons
géographiques absolument évidente
donc ici ce n'est pas un problème de gaz
russe est un problème de politique des
pays européens qui ne sont plus à même
de défendre leurs intérêts stratégiques
qui est celui d'une collaboration
normale et pacifié avec la russie ce qui
veut pas dire que tous les intérêts des
pays européens concorde toujours avec
des intérêts de la russie en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est qu'une politique
de confrontation n'est absolument pas du
tout dans l'intérêt des pays européens
en revanche elle est dans l'intérêt de
l'union européenne qui ne défend pas les
intérêts européens
alors la russie n'est pas la seule à
avoir subi des sanctions il ya la
birmanie le venezuela loi là
hong kong bélarus on rappelle un ce sont
les violations des droits fondamentaux
qui est en cause
pardonnez-moi la naïveté de la question
mais comment ça se passe pour voilà
décréter qu'un pays a violée oui ou non
les droits fondamentaux il ya une sorte
de mini pro ça au sein de la commission
européenne
comment on décrète ainsi des sanctions
au sein des 27 vous avez exactement mis
le doigt son problème c'est qu'il n'y a
strictement aucun procès dans le sens où
il n'y a strictement n'y aucune garantie
procédurale n'y aucune garantie
judiciaire
c'est une décision strictement politique
qui s'appuie sur une division du monde
extrêmement simple extrêmement primaire
il y a d'un côté les siens que l'on ne
condamne pas poitiers se passe il peut
se passer à 100 ch
il peut se passer dé répression violente
des manifestations en france ou en
allemagne
peu importe aux états unis peu importe
il n'y aura strictement aucune sanction
et puis il ya les autres il ya ceux qui
ne se plient pas complètement comme il
faut aux règles du jeu global aux
intérêts atlantis
on voit le venezuela qui n'a pas fait le
bon choix puisqu'il n'a pas fait le
choix de boîte au bon choix dans le sens
évidemment le baliste on voit exactement
aussi le même problème avec tirano ce
cas en biélorussie qu'elle même a
déclaré qu'ils ont perdu la rue donc ils
ont perdu le combat à l'intérieur du
pays on voit l'échec total du combat de
la vanille en russie qui n'a pas réussi
à prendre la rue puisque à part quelques
manifestations ponctuelles
il n'y a eu aucun soulèvement populaire
massif a donc c'est une décision ce sont
des décisions strictement politiques qui
sont là en fait pour sanctionner ceux
qui ne se plie pas aux règles du jeu
c'est un peu si vous voulez la réaction
d'un mauvais roi qui va se fâcher contre
ces sujets parce que ces sujets sont
désobéissant et il ne respecte pas sa
voix ya une volonté nous sommes quand
même dans une vision des choses quelque
peu primaire merci en tout cas à karine
bêcher goal of god avoir été avec nous
avoir apporté votre point de vue
l'univers le niger à présent qu'il
devrait connaître ces prochains jours le
nom du successeur de mamadou issoufou le
dépouillement est en cours après le
second tour de la présidentielle qui
s'est déroulée hier un traitants a
marqué par la mort de sept agents
électoraux
leur véhicule a roulé sur une mine dans
une zone en proie au terrorisme mexique
a bola le second tour des élection
présidentielle entachée par un nouveau
drame alors que la population voter pour
élire son nouveau président le niger a
connu la perte d'agents électoraux et
c'est dans la région de tillabéri à
l'ouest du pays que leur véhicule a
roulé sur une mine qui venait d'être
posée le bilan humain est lourd sept
morts et trois blessés j'ai appris avec
regret et tristesse
l' attaque terroriste qui a causé la
mort de sept agents de la ceni dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions en cette
circonstance douloureuse
j'adresse mes condoléances aux familles
des victimes et souhaite un prompt
rétablissement aux blessés
cet attentat a probablement perpétré par
des djihadistes et le deuxième depuis le
coup d'envoi des élections lors du
premier tour une centaine de personnes
avaient été tuées lors de l'attaqué du
village
dans cette même région de tillabéry et
des drames qui interviennent à un moment
crucial du pays
c'est un grand choc où nous nous tous à
un moment historique de notre pays
historique parce que nous avons des
élections qui pour la première fois de
leur histoire depuis 60 ans qui sont que
se déroule le taste of kain président
démocratiquement élu passe le témoin à
un autre président démocratiquement élu
les résultats du second tour des
élections présidentielles au niger ne
seront connus que dans plusieurs jours
le temps que l'ensemble des bulletins de
vote soit dépouillé les électeurs
avaient le choix entre deux candidats
mohamed bazoum fidèles du président
sortant et mahamane ousmane ancien
président de la république dans les
années 90 le futur chef d'état nigérien
aura donc fort à faire dans un
territoire où l'insécurité règne
le niger est régulièrement visée par des
groupes djihadistes affiliés à l'état
islamique à l'ouest et par boko haram
à l'est du pays et pour en parler nous
sommes avec l louis keumayou président
du club de l'information africaine
bonsoir oui travail ou merci d'être avec
nous en direct de niamey avant d'évoquer
l'élection en elle-même un mot justement
sur ces sept agents électoraux de la
commission électorale nationale
indépendante qui ont trouvé la mort dans
l'explosion de leur véhicule dans le sud
ouest donc du niger proche du mali
qu'est-ce que cela dit cela dit que nous
sommes dans un pays où le risque zéro
n'a pas été gâté je pense qu'il n'y a
aucun pays
aujourd'hui dans le monde qui peut dire
qu'il est à l'abri d'une attaque
terroriste de cette nature là puisqu'il
s'agit d'un engin explosif improvisé qui
déposait de près artisanes et c'est un
ace sur lequel il est difficile de
d'exercer un contrôle régulier
les autorités ont probablement déployé
eu tout ce qu'il fallait pour protéger
les populations qui se rendaient aux
élections mais quand on pose d'un engin
comme celui là cela peut se faire à
n'importe quel moment
l'acce qui est très tenté il ya de
nombreuses voitures qui sont passés
avant d'autres qui sont passés après ce
véhicule a sauté
il faut dire que c'est une attaque
contre le projet démocratique mais que
la réaction devrait être de la part du
niger de montrer que sa démocratie ne
dépend pas que des attaques terroristes
et que l'élection permettra de renforcer
à la fois la démocratie mais surtout les
institutions car de cette démocratie là
puisqu'on a quand même un pays où le
président aurait pu modifier la
constitution pour se présenter une
troisième fois
ils ne l'appellent à passer la mer en
dauphin et il se il est fort possible
que ce dauphin l'emportent donc je pense
que ce serait dommage que l'on réduit
cette élection aux accidents qui ont été
qui ont eu lieu en cours de processus
qui dit démocratie dit quand même allés
voter sereinement est ce que c'est le
cas est ce que les nigériens
en plus voter sereinement selon vous il
ya eu quelques attaques qu'il y a eu
quatre attaques à peu près qui on est et
perd taulier des gens qui ont essayé de
prendre des deux urnes pour partir
d'autres qui ont essayé d'empêcher les
gens de se rendre dans les urnes en
faillite quelques camions et nous les
missions d'observation électorale tête
une conférence de presse demain
c'est-à-dire ce mardi qu on aura
l'occasion d'en savoir un peu plus sur
tous ces faits qui ont été documentés et
sur les élites exprimant leur point de
vue en tant qu'observateur ce que j'ai
pu suivre mois à banias mais c'est que
les choses se sont passées d'affaires de
22,7 ordinaire mais vous savez que nous
sommes dans un pays qui est très grand
dont au moins le trois-quarts se trouve
tout près du désert du sahara et que
cette partie d'un territoire n'est pas
suffisamment contrôlé au nord justement
on al ahly dit qu'il ya un état failli
on à alès la révision de boko haram est
plus à l'ouest
on a cette zone des trois frontières qui
concerne le niger le mali et le port
face aux forces marcal est censé
apporter plus de sécurité il ya eu une
réunion d'ailleurs avant le début de
cette élection qui a permis que le
protégeant tient soir en corse et dans
le disque type sel on se met pas suffi
je pense qu'on en a encore pour quelques
années à combattre le terrorisme dans le
sahel et plus précisément au niger alors
parlant de l'élection le camp du
président sortant ont présenté par
mohamed bazoum est sorti en tête de ce
premier tour largement des avec 39% des
voix quand vous analysez ce chiffre je
pense que c'est déjà nouvelle pour
casser nigérienne que les électeurs et
deux round
d'élection prononcer plus jeunes la
personne qui va présider aux destinées
du pays
il ya eu beaucoup de coups car comme on
les aime rester d'un bar et le premier
tour deux candidats qui étaient en place
et c'est bien pour le jeu démocratique
que qui a un peu de suspens et que au
bout de tours d'élection les citoyens le
choix on élague et parce que n'oublions
pas qu'il ya eu trente candidats lors du
premier tour et que dans le du tout il
choisit pitt ablement le candidat sur
lequel ils estiment qu'ils ont des
meilleurs promettent par rapport à
l'avenir du pays ou sur lequel ils ont
l'impression que les engagements pris en
termes de programmes d'euros cependant
le plus à leurs aspirations donc de mon
point de vue c'est une bonne chose
qu'ils aient eu deux tours et qu' aucun
des candidats n'est plus revenir avant
ce deuxième tour plus de 600 des et
exprime alors clairement un louis
keumayou quels sont les grands chantiers
qui attendent le futur président le
niger pour cette mandature
il y avait plusieurs le premier et le
plus important c'est déjà celui de la
sécurité
c'est de pouvoir et les nigériens le
fait que leur pays peut redevenir un
havre de paix le deuxième celui de
l'appliquer sanin aussi parce que
n'oublions pas que le billet atteint et
frappé aussi par la crise sanitaire ou
dans des conditions où il faudrait et
les mesures terre
mais au delà des mesures sanitaires se
sont toutes les conséquences les
dommages collatéraux qui seront produits
par le confinement et toutes les mesures
d'arrière et à la lutte contre la
pauvreté 19
et puis à tous les chantiers urgents on
a entendu tous les pièges sur la qualité
pourra mettre bazzo qui lui protesté
parce qu'on estime qu'il est arabe et
qu'il appartient à une minorité qui est
très faible et qui est originaire de la
libye dont je crois qu'il ya ceci si tu
n'es ce qu'il faut repenser d'urgence
sociale qu'il faut également remplir et
puis y'a tout le chantier de
l'intégration afrique
le chantier de mocratie le chantier de
l'éducation des jeunes de leur emploi
les chantiers et donc je pense
il n'y aura peut-être pas d'état de
grâce mais il y aura surtout un but
pour le chef est lui dedans dans ses
habits et de retisser tout le lien
social qui a manqué de rassurer ses
compatriotes sur sécurité et le
développement d'habiletés sociales
merci à louis keumayou président du club
de l'information africaine d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france
l'ambassadeur d'italie luca attanasio
été tuées ce lundi en rdc lors de
l'attaqué d'un convoi de l'onu en
déplacement dans une région dangereuse
du pays
les véhicules ont été pris pour cible
par des attaquants armés deux autres
personnes ont été tuées kinshasa
accusent les rebelles hutus rwandais des
fdlr d'être à l'origine de l'attaqué
solène goda l'italie en deuil à
l'annoncé lundi de la mort de deux
fonctionnaires italiens ont république
démocratique du congo lors d'une attaque
armée nous activons toutes les
institutions compétentes pour arriver le
plus vite possible à connaître la vérité
sur cette attaque
abject qu'on subit deux serviteurs de
notre pays qui ont perdu la vie nous
faisons aussi tout notre possible pour
rapatrier leurs corps in italy il plaît
ma poche et bill parmi les victimes
l'ambassadeur italien ont rdc lucas
antanas sio âgé de 43 ans il était en
poste depuis octobre 2019 il résidait
dans le pays depuis déjà deux ans ce
lundi il accompagnait un convoi de la
monusco la mission des nations unies
dans le pays depuis 20 ans l'attak a eu
lieu au nord de goma chef lieu de la
province du nord kivu une région en
proie à des violences perpétrées par des
groupes armés depuis plus de 25 ans
blessé par balle à l'abdomen
lucas en ta nation est décédé dans un
hôpital à goma dans la foulée de la tacc
les forces armées congolaises ont lancé
une opération de recherche des auteurs
selon les autorités locales quatre
personnes auraient été kidnappées
une d'entre elles a depuis été retrouvés
ce lundi soir dans un communiqué le
ministère congolais de l'intérieur
accuse les rebelles hutu rwandais des
forces démocratiques de libération du
rwanda d'être responsable de la tacc en
convois du programme alimentaire mondial
elle a été victime d'une attaque armée
des éléments des forces démocratiques de
libération du rwanda à kinshasa la
capitale les habitants sont sous le choc
c'est difficile pour nous nous
n'arrivons pas d'air à supporter ce
communiqué message là ça me fait
vraiment très mal de savoir qui est
quelqu'un bien et puis très jeunes
mourir à cette circonstance là c'est
vraiment difficile et choquant pour nous
cette question de sécurité à lester
république démocratique du congo a fait
beaucoup de victimes mais voilà
aujourd'hui tout le monde est concerné
un ambassadeur en poste en république
démocratique du congo vient de succomber
de son côté l'union européenne se dit
extrêmement préoccupé par l'annoncé de
la mort de l'ambassadeur d'italie
le pays a connu des précédents en 1993
c'est l'ambassadeur français philippe
bernard qui a trouvé la mort atteint
mortellement par une balle à la fenêtre
de son bureau à kinshasa et à goma
toujours en république démocratique du
congo les élèves reprennent le chemin de
l'école les corps ont été suspendues il
ya maintenant plus de deux mois en cause
l'arrivée d'une deuxième vague de
l'épidémie covit 19 le retour dans les
écoles et les facs se fait dans le
strict respect des règles d'hygiène
sanitaire
un reportage signé pas comme magendie
avec glawdys mort à basile au récit est
signée emilie gogh h
après plus de deux mois sans école
l'heure de la rentrée a sonné ici à
l'institut zehner un établissement
d'enseignement secondaire 1 agents
vérifient la température de chaque élève
dès l'entrée puis il faut se laver les
mains
les élèves doivent également porter un
masque une obligation qu'ils prennent
avec philosophie
pour eux l'important est de pouvoir
revenir étudier ça me touche au niveau
du nez
je me sens vraiment mal à l'aise mais
l'important c'est d'être inflation je ne
me sens pas protégé mais c'est nous qui
allons donner alors cette impression
d'être protégée parce qu'ils ont
respecté les mesures d'hygiène suisse en
cédant ses clients si nous portons des
masques et ça peut aussi nous protéger
d'une manière à une autre mais le savons
que des pôles de masques
c'est aussi en deux éléments qui peut
nous aider à faire face et à leurs
grandes pandémies des grandes villes
nos grands vraiment qui est même en mars
et avril à l'école andalouse
les élèves ont également pour consigne
de ne pas se saluer en se serrant la
main et d'éviter d'échanger leurs
affaires scolaires l'enseignant lui
aussi doit porter un masque
un peu plus loin au collège - ga les
mesures sont à peu près les mêmes sauf
dans les salles de classe cette fois
plus de banc les élèves sont assis mais
chacun sur sa chaise
mais pour certains ce n'est pas encore
assez je dirais sur semble nous sentons
protégé à 80% vu que je pense à mon
humble avis que c'est pas suffisant de
d'être à quelques mètres de distance
mettre nos masques en plus deux fois vu
que c'est gênant nous sommes obligés de
les enlever
c'est pas vraiment rassurant pour le
responsable des études tout est fait
pour que les deux mille élèves de
l'établissement ne tombent pas malades
l'équipe s'en assure y compris pendant
les pauses anti la récréation ils se
sentent tout peut être éparpillés dans
tera nous avons aussi la cour tout à
fait grande aussi et ça permet à ce que
les enfants ne soient pas confinés
ensemble il ya de quoi être vraiment
séparés pour ne pas être vraiment
ensemble
la ministre provinciale de l'éducation
s'est également rendu dans cet
établissement
il s'agit de vérifier que les mesures
barrières sont bien respectées
nous allons continuer à faire la
sensibilisation parce que c'est nous les
parents et tout le monde qui doit
s'impliquer pour que nous ne puissions
pas avoir des cadets coronavirus dans
des écoles la république démocratique du
congo reste relativement épargnée par la
pandémie
depuis que celle ci a commencé le pays a
comptabilisé plus de 25000 15 700
personnes sont décédées ducobu 19 aces à
la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi dans quelques instants un
point complet sur l'actualité de la
journée avec pierre quai saint jean
verne
[Musique]
comment vous jugez maintenant la façon
dont on a géré la crise parce que c'est
arrivé cette histoire personne ne
prenait pas au sérieux nos métiers il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont compris a pris
les choses en main mais c'est presque
inévitable que l'on met tout le monde
dans le même panier et à dire que la
boîte de nuit le bistrot de quartier
à quelles conditions pires gagna allons
nous pouvoir ré ouvrir les restos j'ai
pas les clés mon jeu je produis je
travaille je
j'essaie de faire au mieux c'est aussi
tout un questionnement sur la société
sur le rapport à la solidarité et le
commerce
c'est le commerce et le sait le lien
entre dans le monde
est ce que vous vous allez vous faire
vacciner vous trois fois ci il faut un
évidemment
et y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droite il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une ici